[Music]
what if we let people think that we were
actually together let's do this you are
bringing representation that we don't
often see in a love story do you feel
like we have so so far to go for more
inclusion in film and TV of course we
have a long way to go but I do think
we're making baby steps right and you
know that's all you can hope for change
start somewhere and I think right now
like I mean with this movie and with
crazy rich Asians that's coming out and
so things are happening and I do think
that there's a disruptive force in
Hollywood and it and everything is
changing because studios are realizing
like people want to see the real world
exactly
cuz we're not stupid and we know what
life looks like outside of the screen so
that should imitate what's going on out
here most writers have that hope to see
their story come to life in a new way I
really wanted to come true in part
because I never seen a Native American
girl be the lead of a teen movie before
you know and I think that's a romantic
comedy I think you should branch out
make some new friends you never know
what could happen as an Asian American
actress I'm so happy to be a part of it
it's the first time that Asian Americans
have been leads in a film in like 25
years and it's it's so fun to be a part
of that and movies not centered on that
it's about her and her life and her
journey and she happens to be from an
asian-american family and I love
that's just kind of like a side note it
shouldn't be that we're in 2018 you and
Sandra Oh is the first asian-american
woman to be best active when like a Best
Actress knob that shouldn't be happening
tell me yeah you know and that's where
we have a long ways to go
dad why are you giving me these don't
forget to have fun that's why I have a
lot of rubbers for that specific
[Music]